600,000 subscribers that's a lot of
people how does that even look like this
is the famous 1969 Woodstock concert it
had four hundred thousand attendees so
for me to have six hundred thousand
subscribers
makes me very grateful I just want to
thank each and every single one of you
from those who just subscribed yesterday
to those who have been a longtime
subscriber it shows that people want
something different
I think ColdFusion is just getting
started I've got so many ideas as to
where I want to take this concept I'm
obviously going to leave things like for
how big is series but also broaden my
scope a little I think we're at a
pivotal point in world history right now
when you look around there's so many
things happening with technological
breakthroughs massive shifts in the way
business is conducted and of course
inventions on the horizon like true
artificial intelligence and I want to
bring it all to you in future videos as
a side point I really think that
changing the name from cold fusion to
cold fusion really helped the channel
was at about 230,000 when I took the tea
from the name and that was late last
year so that's almost tripled the number
of subscribers in about six months very
exciting stuff for a bit of a
celebration of crossing the 600,000 mark
I'll be releasing a music mix of all the
burn water tracks that I've created and
yeast in cold fusion videos so you can
look forward to that
so I think that's about it I guess if
you guys want to know me a little bit
better and in an interesting way you can
check out my blog commentary' that I
made about America it's a travel vlog
and documentary of my observations of
American life and culture with a few
stories from my trip from people I met
along the way and the kicker the trip
was mostly done on a tour bus with 50
people and we drive 5,000 miles across
America it's an interesting watch and
I'll leave the link for that below so
yeah I think that's about it thanks guys
so much and I guess I'll see you again
soon for the next video which will still
be on google's deepmind still working on
that one where are cheers guys catch you
later
okay
you